we now know how to find the area of an
equilateral triangle what i want to do
in this video is attempt to find the
area of a and i i know i'm
mispronouncing it a koch or coach
snowflake and the way you construct one
is you start with an equilateral
triangle and then on each of the sides
you split them into thirds and in the
middle third you put another smaller
equilateral triangle
and that's after one pass and on the
next pass you do that for all of the
sides here so a little one here here
here here here here here i think you get
the general idea that's the next best
and the next patch you do it from all of
these sides and what's really neat about
this and we showed this in a previous
video is that you have a figure here
that has an infinite perimeter but we're
about to see in this video it actually
has a finite area which is kind of
interesting to think about so let's
start with a clean a clean equilateral
triangle right over here
we're going to assume that each of the
sides have length s
so it's going to be a clean equilateral
triangle each of the sides drive that a
little bit neater each of the sides have
length s and so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to keep track of two things
i'm going to keep track of the sides in
this triangle
as we are as as it turns into a
snowflake i'm going to keep track of the
number of sides and i'm going to keep
track of the area after each pass of
adding more smaller triangles so this is
going to be our count of the area
actually let me give myself a little bit
more real estate just because i have a
feeling i might need to use it so i'm
going to keep this is the sides i'm
going to write up here and then this is
our running count of the area down here
so right when we start
we have three sides
we have three sides and our area we
already figured out in a previous video
is going to be if we assume each of the
sides or length s is going to be square
root of 3
square root of 3 s squared
over 4. fair enough that was just a
simple equilateral triangle now we're
going to take each of these sides divide
them into thirds
so we're going to take each side divide
it into thirds
and then in that middle third we're
going to add another smaller equilateral
triangle so it'll look like that on that
side right over there and i want i want
you to think about what we're doing to
each side right here so before i did
this this was just one side then i split
it into thirds and that middle third i
put i essentially put two sides in there
i put an equilateral triangle so one
side has now turned into
one 2 3 4 sides so every time we do a
pass of the making the snowflake more
intricate each side will turn into four
sides so you can imagine if we do this
on all three sides
we have 4 times 3 which is now 12 sides
so if you multiply this times 4
so times 4 this gets us to 12 sides now
and we can count them out just to make
sure where our logic is correct 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 sides
and now what is the area now what's
going to be the area of our original
yellow equilateral triangle plus the
area of each of these smaller ones and
what's the area of each of these smaller
ones well first of all we have three of
them there are three of these each of
each of these smaller ones and then we
use the formula for the area of an
equilateral triangle again so it's going
to be square root of 3 times
s squared but now the length of each of
the sides of each of these equal these
smaller equilibrium triangles they
aren't s anymore they are s over three
remember this this length right over
here is s over three so this is going to
be s over 3 as well every pass the sides
of the equilateral triangle become 1 3
of the previous pass so this is it's not
going to be s squared anymore it's going
to be s
over 3 squared and then all of that
all of that over 4.
then let's do another pass so we're
going to add these triangles right over
here
i'm going to add these right over there
and this is the last pass where i'll
actually attempt to draw all of the
triangles over there so how many how
many sides am i going to have first of
all after i do another pass well the
previous pass i had 12 sides each of
those 12 sides are now going to turn
into four new sides when i add these
little orange bumps there so i'm going
to multiply it times 4 again i'm going
to multiply it times 4. so now i'm going
to have 48 sides i'm going to have 48
sides and how many new triangles so
what's the area well it's going to be
the yellow area plus the blue area plus
the orange area so how many new orange
triangles do i have well i'm adding a
new orange triangle to each of the sides
for the previous pass in the previous
pass i had 12 sides so now i'm going to
add 12 orange triangles
i'm going to add 12 orange triangles and
actually let me write that i'll just
write 12 orange triangles but it's
really i just multiplied it times 4 and
then i'm going to have times the square
root of 3
and now this isn't going to be s s over
3 anymore these are going to be s over
9. these have one third of the
dimensions of these blue triangles so
this is going to be s
over 9
s over 9 squared
s over 9 squared over 4. and so i think
you might start to see the pattern
building if we do another pass after
this one move to the right a little bit
what will that look like let me do this
in a different color that i haven't used
yet
let me see i haven't used this pink yet
so now i'm going to have i'm going to
have the previous number of sides that's
my number of new triangles 48 times the
square root of 3
times s over i'm going to now these are
going to be even 1 3 of this s over 27 s
over 27 to the second power all of that
over four and i'm going to keep adding
an infinite number of terms of this to
get the area of a true coach snowflake
so i'm just going to keep doing this
over and over again so the trick really
is is finding the this infinite sum and
seeing if it actually if we get a finite
number over here so the first thing i
want to do just to simplify it well let
me just rewrite it a little bit let me
rewrite it a little bit differently over
here
so the first thing that's kind of that
might be obvious is that we can factor
out a square root of three s squared
over four so let me factor that out
so if we factor out a square root of
three s squared over four from all of
the terms then this term right over here
will become a 1.
this term right over here is going to
become a 3. well let's see we factored
out a square root of 3 we factor out a 4
and we factored out the s squared we
factor out only the s squared so now
it's going to have plus three
times
times one third three times one third
squared that's all we have left here we
have the one third squared and then we
have this three and i'm not simplifying
this on purpose so that we see a pattern
emerge
and then this next term right over here
plus so this 12 is still going to be
there but i'm gonna write that as three
times four
three times four and then we're gonna
lose this we're factoring out the square
root of three we're factoring out the
four we're factoring out the s squared
and so we're going to be left with three
squared that's what this is down here
squared so this is one over one third
squared
one 3 squared and then that squared so
that's what we're left with with that
orange term and then we go to the pink
term
this pink term this is 48 is just 3
times 4 times 4. 3 times 4. i'll write 4
squared here because each time we're
going to multiply times 4 again so the x
is going to be 4 to the third because
we're really
each iteration each side turns into 4
sides that's where that came from
4 squared we lose we're factoring out
the square root of 3. we're factoring
out the four we're factoring out the s
squared and all we're left is one over
three to the third power squared so
times one over three to the third power
squared and we're just gonna keep going
like that forever
keep going like that forever
so in each step we are incrementing
we're multiplying by four and we're also
multiplying or where or i guess we say
the power of this four is incrementing
so it goes it goes from there's really
four to the zero power here we have a 1
here you can kind of imagine implicitly
the 4 to the first power 4 squared then
we'll go 4 to the third and then we have
this power is also incrementing 3 to the
first 3 second 3 to the third but we see
that this power is always one more than
that and it'll be much easier to
calculate this infinite what's going to
turn into an infinite geometric series
if those are actually the same power so
what i want to do is i want to increase
the power 4 and all of those but i can't
just really nearly multiply everything
by 4. if i'm going to multiply
everything by 4 i also need to divide
everything by 4. so what i'm going to do
in this step right over here is i'm
going to multiply and divide everything
by 4. so if we divide by 4 i can do that
on the outside so let me multiply 1 4
times this right over here and so i'm
dividing by 4 out here and then i'm
going to multiply this by 4. so i'm not
going to be changing the value of the
actual thing so this is going to be this
is going to be 4
plus
3 times
4
3 times 4
plus 3 times 4 squared 4 to the third
and so what was cool about this is now
that the power of 4 and the power of
this 3 down here are going to be the
same power but it still seems a little
weird because we're taking this 1 over 3
square and then we're squaring it 1 over
3 to the third and then we're squaring
it and here we just have to realize so
this is always going to be squared and
this is the thing that's incrementing
but in general in general if i have 1
over
3 to the n
and i'm squaring it this is equal to 1
over 3 to the 2n
power which is so i'm just multiplying
it by 2.
if i'm raising something exponent then
raising that to an exponent that's just
multiplying it times the or raising it
to the n times two exponent and this is
the exact same thing as 1 over 3 squared
raised to the nth power so we can
actually switch these two exponents in a
very legitimate way and then let me
rewrite everything because i don't want
to do too much on this one step right
over here so this part right over here
gives us square root of 3 s squared over
16
and then that's going to be times i'll
open and close the parentheses so then
we have 4
plus
then in blue i'll write 3 times 4 to the
first power and then i can write this i
can rewrite this as times 1 3. we could
view this as one-third squared or we
could view this we could use this as
one-third of the f one over three to the
first power squared or we could view
this as one over three squared to the
first power and i'm gonna write it that
way so times one-ninth
to the first power
and then plus
3 times 4 squared and then this we can
write as
times
1 9 to the second power
and then
this one we can write plus 3 times 4
to the third times
times and this is we could write this as
1 over 27 is the second power but we
could also write this based on what we
saw over here we could write this as 1
over 3 squared to the third power based
on this right over here let me make this
clear 1 over 3 to the third
to second power this is the same thing
as 1 over 3 squared
to the third power that's what we showed
right over here so this is the
equivalent to
1 9
1 9 to the third power and now we start
to see the pattern it's starting to
clean up it's starting to clean up a
little bit and let me just do one more
step and then we'll finish this in the
next video
so this is equal to square root of 3 s
squared over 16
times 4 plus
4 plus 3
times this is 4 9
plus
the next term is
3 times
4 9 squared 4 9 squared and then we have
plus
plus 3 times 4 over 9 to the
third power and then we're just going to
keep going on and on and on and on
taking three times four nice to the
successively larger and larger powers so
this is what we have to find the sum of
to find our area and we're going to do
that in the next video we're going to
use some of the tools we've used to find
the sums of infinite geometric series
but we're kind of going to redo it in
this video just so that you don't have
to remember that that formula or that
proof